of the complexity of two-party defensive
privacy
uh so this is a joint World creative
stuff
Adia
so let me start by defining uh
differential privacy
so we are going to assume we have some
database X that contain maybe sensitive
information about the participants
and we want to publish some statistics
on this database without revealing any
private information on the participants
so we want uh to well publishing some
accurate statistic we want to
and the output of the function we
published will not reveal too much
information about about one participant
in the database meaning that if we
imagine that one participant
provides a fake input to the database
the distribution of the output of the
function of the mechanism we apply on
the database will not change by much
should be very close
so this is a very strong definition of
privacy in the sense that even we if we
know the entire database but one entry
we cannot reconstruct the this entry
from the output of the mechanism
and to make it former we ask that uh
we say that a mechanism m is Epsilon
Delta differential private if for every
two neighboring database x and x Prime
neighboring it means that they are
different only in one entry
the output the distribution of the
output of M on X is Epsilon Delta Clause
to the distribution of the output of M
on X prime meaning that for every uh
distinguisher may be unbounded
distinguisher the probability that the
distinguisher output one on the output
of the mechanism on x
is bounded by E times e to the Epsilon
times the probability that D output 1
and the output of the mechanism on X
prime plus Delta and this Delta is
usually very small like uh some
negligible or one of the large
polynomials so in this talk we will
think about this Delta as zero
and Epsilon is some small constant so
etode Epsilon is actually a one plus
Epsilon and this means that the
probability of the distinguisher to
Output one on the output of the
mechanism on X is up to the one plus
Epsilon Factor the same probability is
its output one on the output of the
mechanism of X1
and again this is a very strong
definition even if the distinguisher
know anything about the database except
for one entry you cannot distinguish
between the real entry of of the
participant to the effect
so for an example let's assume that Tel
Aviv University want to perform some
survey among the students and it want to
know how many students suffers from high
blood pressure
so the university collects uh data from
the student and now it holds a vector of
length n when n is the number of
students each entry in the vector is
equal to one if the student suffers from
high blood pressure and zero otherwise
and we want to publish the the number of
students that surface for my blood
pressure so we want to publish the sum
of the the entries of the vector
and of course if we uh publish this
sound then this is not a differential
private mechanism because if we know the
entire Vector but one entry we can
reconstruct the remaining entry by
knowing the sound so this is not
differential private mechanism but it
turns out that if we had a small noise
from a specific distribution condo plus
then this mechanism is a differential
part and the amount of Noise We need to
add is a constant in the sense that it
uh
independent from the length of the
vector it's only dependent on Epsilon
okay so this is a very accurate
mechanism to compute the the sum of a
vector
while preserving privacy
but this example for differential
private mechanism in the centralized
model meaning we have one party that all
the entire database and we want to
publish some function of this database
but we can imagine a situation in which
we have two parties
uh Ali sold one database and both a
second database and they want to compute
a function on the joint data so they
want to communicate in order to Output
some function of both X and what
this is the two faulty differential
privacy case and the Privacy notion we
want to achieve is that
um
the view of Alice in the protocol will
preserve the privacy of the participant
in the database of Bob and the view of
Bob in this protocol will preserve the
privacy of the participants in the
database of rallies so we want that for
every input of Alice X and for every two
neighboring databases of Bob the view of
Alice in the protocol when Alice uses X
and Bob uses y will be Epsilon Delta
Clause to the view of Alice in the
protocol when Alice still uses X but Bob
uses y Prime
this means that uh
the view of Alice in the protocol
preserve the privacy of the database of
Boom
and the view is just the input coins and
transcripts and we we ask the same for
formula so we want also that the view of
both will preserve the privacy of the
participants in the database of products
uh so for example if we still Tel Aviv
universities still want to do the survey
of knowing how many students suffers
from high blood pressure but now each
faculty want to do to collect the data
on its own students separately
so the faculty of exact science has this
Vector of all the students in the exact
science
faculty that suffers from high blood
pressures and we have the faculty of
social sciences that all uh
a vector that for the student of the
social sciences faculty and now they
want to know how many people in the
entire University suffers from high
blood pressure but I say that the
faculty of exact science doesn't trust
the faculty of social science uh with
respect to this data
then they want to communicate privately
and in this case it's very simple uh The
Faculty of excel Sciences just can send
a noisy estimation of the number of
students in this faculty that suffers
from high blood pressure
and the faculty of social sciences can
do the same and they can just add this
output and compute that it would have
seen identical influence
uh so it's just uh an assumption that we
don't use it in business
so they just uh published the the sum of
the output and this is a very simple uh
protocol but this is a very simple case
and there are more
complicated functions for example let's
say that we want to measure correlation
so now Alice as Alice and Bob have two
different database on the same set of
participants
Alice as a vector that says for each
participant whether it is smokes or not
so it's a minus one if these participant
smokes and one if it doesn't smoke
and both have the same for high blood
pressure and we want to compute the
correlation between smoking and high
blood pressure
and this is much less clear how to do
but uh if we think about it then the
functionality we want to compute in this
case is the inner product between the
vector of Alice and the vector of Bob
which is exactly the the correlation so
the question of this work is how
complicated is to compute the inner
product between two factors while
preserving plants this is the question
so what do we know
so first of all in the centralized model
if you have one party that all uh bought
vectors and just we want just to publish
the inner quota then uh similar to The
Case of the the sum we can just compute
the inner product and then the LaPlace
noise and we can achieve a constant
error error that's independent of the
input so
in the two particles so assuming that
the vectors of Alice and Bob chosen
uniformly at random we have a very
simple protocol just output 0
and this protocol has a noise of
spiritual fan with very high probability
so we can there is a trivial protocol
that achieve noise
and unfortunately uh and this can be
generalized generalized for and every
input distribution is in the protocol
because the randomized response
but unfortunately this is the best we
can do so there is a lower bound that
says that for any differential private
protocol for computing the inner powder
the noise must be square root of that so
you can not do better
but uh we have a centralized model uh
mechanism that achieve constant error
and we know that using cryptography we
can simulate a trusted party that will
simulate this centralized model
mechanism so using crypto we can achieve
constant error
then I mean not in the distribution of
setting it's trivial but when there's no
distribution yeah
most
and so uh using crypto we can achieve
constantly
and these things like contradict the
lower bound but the issue is that the
Privacy only holds for computational
bounded distinguishes so in order to use
this uh result we need a new definition
of different chapters and for this we
have the definition of computational
differential privacy so when we defined
uh differential privacy we said that uh
this uh distinguished and bound should
earn for every distinguisher even
unbounded one and in computational
differential privacy we just restrict
the distinguisher to be efficient or not
so when you're talking about the
computational protocol you're talking
about like MPC yeah okay so if you want
to achieve nowhere you can just no so if
you want differential appointments you
have to publish a result right okay yeah
uh okay so now
now the distinguisher is just a polytime
distinguisher
and uh in the similar you can Define
two-party computation differential part
with protocol and now we uh acquire that
the view of Alice in the protocol will
preserve the computational differential
private a property with respect to the
database of flow and the cell phone
so now we have a definition of
computational differential privacy and
now we can use a multi-party computation
in order to simulate any centralized
mechanism in the 2006
information theoretically that is there
meaningful natural situations in the
simplest
is
foreign
[Music]
there is a work of Mark Bunn and uh
someone will show something
computation and you can take any Epsilon
data centralized mechanism and convert
it into a very accurate computational
differential environment
in the case of inner product you can
take the centralized mechanism that Ed
LaPlace which has constant 0 and get uh
protocol that Epsilon Dental
computational differential private
protocol with constantials and of course
in order to use the pure multiculty
computation we need to assume of the
oblivious transfer of all things
so we need some
cryptographic assumption and the
question is what is the complex
complexity of two-party computational
differential products so using OT we can
get very accurate
protocols but uh can we do it while only
assuming Runway functions and if you
cannot do it well only assuming when a
function you will really need to assume
public key cryptography or maybe we can
use more reliable assumptions
and even if we do need to use public key
cryptography
do we really need to use the heavy
computational every secure multiparty
computation or maybe we can do something
more efficient so the the question in
this book is what is the complexity
specifically what is the complexity of
inner products
so we have this complexity other key
when the minimal assumption for
cryptography is one way function which
is uh equivalent to all these nice
Primitives and all things sufficient for
multi-party computation and in the
middle we have kilogram and and we want
to know where to build a non-trivial
distributed autophatic computational
differential policy
when a non-trivial is anything that we
can do in the centralized model
but any accuracy we can achieve in the
centralized model or with computational
differential privacy but we cannot
achieve uh in the two-party model with
differential parts
so we
can achieve each such uh
task using OT and each it's not out to
see that non-trivial distributed
computational differential policy imply
one-way function
but we want to know where to put it
between our TN functions
so the special case of computing dexo
and Alice on one bit and Bob odd one bit
and they want to publish some estimation
of the Excel then we know that this is
equivalent to what so for this specific
task we know that the complexity of this
specific task is exactly okay but
um
for in order to publish a estimation of
the Excel between Alice and Bob the
estimation need to be very noisy because
when we know the soil and we know what
one bit we can compute the other one so
the accuracy of any uh protocol to
computex saw is is very bad so no one is
going to compute so in the differential
private way this is not a natural
task and the more natural task is to
compute the correlation of the inner
products so this is actually a more
interesting
a question
and for this uh we only know that we can
use Auto in order to construct it and we
knew that there is a separation from one
a function to this so we can not use
one-way function in a black box like in
order to compute the inner product but
we didn't know uh where to put it
exactly
and in our work we showed that uh we can
use any inner product protocol
differential private in reported
protocol in order to construct
caregiving protocol so if you want to
construct such protocol you must assume
that key element exists
what is special about inner product in
your result like what property does it
generalize to others no so uh the result
the the construction of the protocol
that we will see is uh use the some
properties of the inner product and we
cannot generalize it for other
properties it uh that's not for example
for the harming distance because there
is a simple reduction between I mean
distance to Inner products so any
functionality that you can prove a
reduction from it to an opponency so you
don't have like a clear way to specify
the properties so we will see it should
be it's not particular it's like exactly
no product
inner product s were
the tourists
do you have any instructions on the
wrong complexity or
uh no so uh we actually take uh you know
any number of a file then we get a care
dealing with I guess one or two more
months
again what is your definition of
non-trivial because even is anything you
can do in the computer with
computational differential privacy but
you cannot do uh
so how many rounds is your final product
sorry so it's depends on the number of
uh
so now the other way we don't know right
we don't know if you need key agreement
or OT all right but there is a very
recent uh result the show that care unit
is not enough
[Music]
and um we will use a uh some
more relaxed definition of defunctual
privacy we only need the protocol to be
differential private with respect to
outside distinguisher so we only want
the transcript to respect the
differential private of the of both Alex
and bomb and then it's uh equivalent
you don't know how to use the fact that
uh the differential privacy population
on with respect to Alice and Bob in
order to to get empty but we believe
that the rights are services
sorry you answer this just now but I
don't understand why do you need the
word non-trivial and that green box what
if you just wrote CDP IP so we will see
the the top results
uh
so here is the the exact player so let's
assume that uh Pi is a protocol which is
Epsilon Delta uh computational
differential apartment for small enough
data
that for some number L satisfies that if
we uh choose the input at random and
compute the output of the protocol the
distance between the output of the
protocol to the real linear product is
smaller than L with probability larger
than L of the skeleton
if there's such guarantee we can use the
protocol Pi in order to construct
pyramid photographer yeah
so if you take uh Epsilon to be constant
and L to B is square root of n over C
then we get that uh any protocol with a
QRC with constant probability less than
square root of n
implies
so this proves the rip of the
information theoretic result
we cannot have uh
real differential private protocol that
is accuracy less than square root of n
with high probability because we can use
such protocols
and more generally so I said uh that
this is true for any and we actually
need the cell to be larger than log air
but uh other than this this is uh tied
up to a constant in the sense that the
protocol that output just output 0
is L at most every probability all of us
go to Fair
so if we get something which is a little
better than the the trivial protocol you
can use it in order to construct
okay so let's see uh the information
theoretic proof uh yes
what do you use Delta exactly so we just
need better to mix more than
so in the definition of differential
appointments
but we can think about this sentence
so let's see the information to what the
idea behind the information theoretical
problem
so assume we have a protocol Phi which
is Epsilon differential private
and we choose the inputs X and Y
uniformly at random and then we run the
protocol and get a transcript team and
if this protocol file is accurate
protocol for the inner product then uh
distance T contains a estimation to the
inner product accurate estimation
then so if you have such file then it's
for any protocol it all that the input
of Alice given the transcript is
independent from the input of flow given
the transcript so x given T and Y given
T again dependent on the development
this is true for every uh two-party
protocol
and a second property we have from the
Epsilon differential privacy is that if
we know
all the transcripts and the entire
Vector X
but one entry we cannot reconstruct the
last end so the x i is unpredictable
given the transcript and x minus I for
every coordinate I
and such sources that as this property
called a strong center for the running
cells so F given T is a strong sentence
and Y given T the strong sentence and
this the robot independent songs
and it turns out that the inner product
is a good extractor for such sources so
if we take two strong sentence which is
independent we get and take the the
value of the inner product model of
skeleton we get a uniform out
but if the transcript contains a
accurate estimation to the inner product
then the inner product of X and Y given
T should be not random which will be
around the destination so this means
that any uh Epsilon differential privacy
protocol for the inner product
is noise at least goes
number one is just a fact yeah number
one is
okay so this is the information
theoreticals and now we want to use it
in order to prove the computational
so in the computational case now Chi is
a computational differential private
protocol and it's still true that X and
Y are independent given across this is
State one but now uh X and Y are only
computationally strong certification
sources in the sense that any
computational abundant adversary cannot
reconstruct any anti of x given the x
minus I but information theoretically we
may it may be possible to those
and uh for such sources inner product is
not a good example so independent
computational strong Center but the
running sources in our product is not a
good start and this solves because if
you assume that OT exists then we have a
very accurate protocol for the inner
product
and then uh the inner product given the
transcript of this protocol is fixed or
is close to the estimation of the the
output of the protocol so this proves
that assuming that OT exists the inner
product is not a good extent
so what happened here we have two
sources which are independent and no
computation abundance
algorithm can
reconstruct a bit for me given the the
other bit so it's computation is strong
sort of position is also so in the eyes
of uh computational abundant algorithm
the sources are Center Vaseline and and
they should be independent so the inner
product should be should have known it
should be extractable but it isn't so
this implies that uh in the eyes of
computation a bounded adversaries there
is a correlation between X and Y so in
the eyes of computational abundant
adversaries X and I and Y are not
independent the laser dependency between
them
and our goal in the uh here in order to
use such a protocol in order to
construct your government protocol is to
extract this correlation
we want to extract this dependency to
get uh
okay so let's see the
the correlation is in the eye of the
atmos eye of the party right but we only
need to get this correlation against uh
if
so this is just an intuition when you
see the
you don't want to get the correlation
against T if you want if to think
to know nothing about the key and have a
correlation between Alice and Bob so
come on so it's actually it knows that
the eyes of people they call it because
the inner spot that appears in 12th
so think about going into key agreements
you're saying in the key agreement and
it's not just in the eye of these have a
correlated key
correlated kill him it's exactly
so think about uh one bit care demon
right so in the iso so given the
transcript the output of Alice and Bob
are independent so there is no
correlation given the transcript between
our example but in the eyes of it the
output of Alice is equal probability are
zero and with probability Alpha One and
the output of verb
so this is a computational correlation
in reality there is no correlation
between the output of factors
oh maybe fixed so yeah
so in this sense
okay so if I lost you so far this is a
great point to come back we are going to
see how to take a inner product protocol
and to convert it into a key again so
we'll we'll take in an you know protocol
and construct the key again protocol
this protocol doesn't it's not going to
be a really caregiver protocol it's only
or will have some
weak notion of agreement and security
but I will explain what we get after we
will see the problem
so
um in the first step of the protocol
analysis is just going to choose the
random input and Bob is also going to
choose the random Vector of plant and
and they are going to run the inner
product protocol in order to get an
estimation for the inner product between
them
this is the first step
and now Alice is going to choose a
random Vector in zero one to the end so
we are going to think about this Vector
as I said
and she's going to send
the L Vector X restricted on the set up
so she is going to send XL which is
x i for each entry I for which array is
equal to 1.
so up to an ordering of the entrance in
the search is going to send one alpha
possible she sends nothing also yes it's
possible
and uh Bob is going to stand the
complementary set so it is going to send
y minus r which is y i for every entry
for which alright is equal to zero
so Bob sends the complement to a set and
now both of them can compute the inner
product in on the vector of the F so Bob
can compute the inner product between XL
and Y R and Alice can compute the inner
product between x minus y r and Y minus
at least not
um
X well you don't need it to be pregnant
the point is that uh Neve doesn't know
why
so she cannot compute the Daniel product
between accent
sorry when you say differential product
don't you want to say that uh the book
The you know the protocol it's not your
private but uh this protocol just
appeared in photocature so we'll show
that okay okay okay
so now
if so so the output of Love is going to
be Excel at the end of modification and
the output of Alice is going to be the
output of the you know protocol minus x
minus r y equals
and just notice that uh if the output of
the inner product protocol is uh
equals
then Alice and Bob agree because the sum
of the inner product between X and Y R
plus x minus r and Y minus L is exactly
emotionally the agreement of this
protocol says that uh the distance
between the output of Alice to the
output of verb is exactly the noise of
the particle so if the the protocol the
inner product protocol is accurate then
the output of Alice and output of mobile
are close to each other
and uh what we need to achieve for
secrecy is that no algorithm if that get
uh the transcript of the inner product
protocol uh the set of XR and my y minor
cell all the transcripts of the key
element protocol for each uh polynomial
time uh address array if we want that
the output of this algorithm will be
found uh from the output flow and in
order to amplify this protocol into qdma
we need that uh with sample ability the
output of it will be more far from the
output of love than the output valid so
Alice has some advantage over even in
guessing the output
this will be enough
and the intuition is that uh since
if doesn't know y r and Y R is very
unpredictable given the the on
transcript of this protocol the inner
product of Excel and bio should be
foreign
but the proof is not even and it uses a
new theorem about strong center of the
Germany sunset
but in a special case in which the arrow
of the inner product protocol is small
then the when the expected L of this
protocol is smaller than square root of
n over some poly log then the proof is
relatively simple
yeah I don't think I have time to to
show you it but the puff is not very
complicated so
so
stressing out the time so
I think about it at the output
[Music]
so
so now again so Alice and Bob are kind
of like within one each other
or Alice can guess Bob up to this one
over Epsilon error and for here if you
have confusion about what the
um
like what the error should be so it
should be
um around Toyota Fair
because uh if you take uh to
Independence
so this is what we expected
so maybe we will see a simple example
um
so uh to prove this log don't we get a
new theorem about strong Center
pasionally sources and
um the theorem is a c dependent
condenser for strong Santa Rosa so we
actually proved that if X and Y uh
and we choose a seed our uniformly at
random and then we look on the inner
product between x r and Y out then this
inner product as I mean entropy the
larger than squamous n even if the if we
see the seed out and some liquid
dependent
about X and that and Y so we get also XR
and Y minus r this still has uh
so this is uh
see dependent liquid
and still we can
get some minantopy and the poof is by a
constructive Port so we have an
efficient algorithm a construction
algorithm work that's given an index I
and uh this leakage can reconstruct
a bit of X and Y to well
and then this also holds from
computational strong sometimes
[Music]
so this is a second theorem we have
questions
no so it's not even when you have a
leakage uh C dependent
but uh if you don't have this leakage
then this just follows from the fact
that uh
the inner product of course
information
okay so I think I don't have time to
show you the ideas from the book but uh
again the in in the simple case the the
book is very simple
it's what uh symbolizes are close
when the the noise is uh bounded on
expectation the noise can be loud it can
be spelled to fan but the expected noise
is is not spelled a fan of dialogue
um
yeah so uh in the in the general case
the noise should be small smaller than
air with a small probability so the
probability that uh
the AOE small can be very very small in
the simple case we assume that the noise
can be loud but it holds for like
it's very high probability so this is
why the the professor
so to conclude uh we showed that uh
non-trivial computation differential
private protocol for the inner product
imply uh care agreement and open
question is uh
finding a more General character
resident that capture more
functionalities more than the inner
products and determine whether we need
OT or we can use a chronic urinal
protocol and as I said our result is
tied for a differential privacy against
external mode so in this case
same question what do you mean by DP
against external so we only wanted
someone with that sees the planting uh
will not uh we will not get any
information about it oh so you don't
mean Alice and Bob
okay
so what do you mean required Force like
CP IP like because we showed
so we should just do like an accurate
one where we showed that we can do an
inaccurate one and show that uh
the question is if care limiting is
enough or maybe reading it is uh I see
foreign
[Music]